britain was facing an energy crisis
before russia's invasion of ukraine
tightened an already historic squeeze on
living standards
as energy prices rise more than 50
percent the boss of britain's fourth
largest provider said worse is to come
the price caps going up because we had a
global energy crisis
exacerbated by the terrible war in
ukraine
um and
in the short term the uk stuck with
these energy prices the reality you know
the way our energy system works is that
you know if we're not buying russian gas
even if the uk is not buying it it will
be diverted somewhere else what we need
to do as a
society
is start to wean ourselves off gas
altogether
in six months natural gas prices have
risen seven times higher than
pre-pandemic but the increase we're
paying today was set in february three
weeks before the invasion of ukraine
caused fresh volatility
prices are forecast to rise even higher
up from today's
1971 pounds for average household dual
fuel use
to 2 600 pounds in october before
falling back to 2041 pounds next april
the government has provided up to 350
pounds in loans and grants to households
but this squeeze won't just pinch the
poor
one thing we found is that the number of
people who are going to spend more than
10 of their total household budgets on
energy is going to soar if energy bills
hit 2 500 pounds this winter we'll have
a third of households paying 10 of their
total budgets on energy bills which is
you know which is a sign of being what's
called fuel stress where you're
struggling with your energy bills
a government energy strategy setting out
plans for renewables like solar and wind
to loosen the grip of oil and gas has
been delayed but we already know we'll
be relying on gas-fired power stations
like this for years to come
ending our reliance on hydrocarbons
should be a virtuous circle delivering
cheaper abundant energy with less
environmental damage and dependence on
dictators and despotic regimes the
trade-off is it's going to take decades
in the short term cutting demand may be
one of the few ways consumers can fight
back if you insulate your home simply
using loft insulation cavity wall
insulation you cut your gas demand by 20
which is a 20 reduction in your gas bill
and that can happen very very quickly
you know in the short term whereas if
you're looking at fracking or north sea
oil and gas that's going to take years
in edinburgh climate protesters mocked
the west's reliance on russia for
millions of families this energy crisis
is very real paul kelso sky news